-Our first guest this evening is
a talented actress
who you know from her work in
films like "Definitely Maybe,"
"Hot Rod,"
and "Wedding Crashers."
She stars in the new series
"Wolf Like Me".
All six episodes will be
available to stream on Peacock
starting tomorrow.
Let's take a look.
-♪ Every fortress falls ♪
-Who put on that song?
-Um, I don't know.
-Did you just put on the song?
-I've been sitting here
with you.
-Um, I need to go.
-Did I do something wrong?
I feel like --
-No, I just feel like this is --
um, I shouldn't have put myself
in this situation.
-What situation?
-I haven't day drunk
in a really long time, so --
-I don't think it's day anymore.
-Really? What time is it?
-After 6:00.
-Huh!
-♪ I don't believe I know you ♪
♪ Yet, I don't truly
know myself ♪
-Please welcome to the show
Isla Fisher.
How are you, Isla?
-I'm good. But, wait.
I love that you're wearing
a flannel shirt
and I'm dressed up
for the Oscars.
-I know, I feel like we do a bad
job of letting our guests know.
[ Laughter ]
This is like we met --
we met on Tinder
and I did a terrible job
of telling you
where we were going to go
for our first date.
-Yes, yes, that is so true.
But I would like --
What's the fancy one?
Isn't it Raya?
We would have met on Raya.
-Oh, we would have been on Raya.
You're right.
We would not have been --
We wouldn't have been
slumming it on Tinder.
[ Laughter ]
Isla, congratulations
on this show,
which has romance elements,
horror elements,
and it is almost impossible
to talk about
without giving something away.
-Yeah, it has been really fun
during press for this movie.
It is like the list of talking
points is just two pages
of what I can't say,
but I will say that
people really seem to have
connected so far.
We've got pretty good reviews,
which I'm really happy about
because I'm very proud of this.
It is sort of like an
exploration of
how difficult it is
to have a romance or to be --
to fall in love,
how scary it is,
and sort of
genre-bending element
is just sort of a reminder of
really the danger
of being open to love
and how the baggage we bring
into relationships.
-One thing we can say because we
did officially give it away
in the clip is the Josh Gad
is in this show,
who is incredibly talented...
-He is.
-...and wonderful,
and it must be nice
to do a show
with somebody like that.
-By the way, completely agree,
Seth.
Thank you for highlighting
the fact that every day onset
was fun.
And as we both know, because
we've been in this business
sadly since "Hot Rod,"
so a very long time,
that often -- that, you know,
those relationships --
Put it this way,
Josh comes to work every day
very happy and
a very supportive scene partner.
I mean, we shot it in Australia
though,
and he was obsessed
with kangaroos
and he just kept saying,
"Isla, where are the kangaroos?"
I'd be like, "Josh, we're
in Sydney, we're in a city."
It is not like we're in --
"There are no kangaroos
in a coffee shop, mate.
You have to
just cool your jets."
But we did have some chickens
and a goat.
So he saw wildlife. Not
necessarily Australian wildlife.
-Did he ever --
over the course of his visit,
did you at least show him
one kangaroo?
Did you send him out
to find one?
-He got --
He got sick when he landed.
Actually, the scene
that you just showed,
sort of the kissing scene,
we both had snot
streaming out of our nose,
so it was not
the most romantic day.
And I feel like every weekend
he had to do --
No, he didn't see a kangaroo.
He didn't even see
a wallaby or a koala.
I'm pretty sure he -- no.
You need to ask him, but I let
him down as a tourist guide.
-Yeah.
-I was not there.
-I can't believe you --
the consolation animal you
showed him was a chicken.
That's really --
I mean, that's really rough.
-Well, that's in the show.
I mean, I didn't even go
out of my way to -- yeah.
-So you --
you and your husband, Sacha,
you celebrated an anniversary
last month.
Is it 20 years?
-Right.
Which in Hollywood standards
is like 200 years.
Golden jubilee.
It is unheard of.
-Congratulations.
And this is a detail
that I will never get tired
of talking about
or hearing about.
You guys met in clown school.
-Right.
We didn't actually meet
in clown school,
but we did both
go to clown school.
-Gotcha. So it is a very --
a very good ice breaker
when you finally met
to talk about clown school.
-Right. I mean, listen.
You know, I studied
with Jacques Lecoq in Paris.
He studied with Philippe Gaulier
in London.
My, you know, red nose was born
in the ninth [indistinct].
His was born in the seventh.
My clown shoes are a 1'5",
and his are only half a foot.
So I like to think that --
No, I'm just kidding.
There's not much clown rivalry
at home,
but there are a lot of
conversations
about commedia dell'arte
and bouffon,
and we can get competitive.
-I can't believe this,
because it was such a --
I mean, it was the first time I
think a lot of people saw you,
was in "Wedding Crashers."
It was such a brilliantly funny
performance,
and yet I recently heard
it was the first comedy role
you ever auditioned for.
-Yeah.
I mean it is weird because
growing up
I had like extra large ears
and I was really short
with red hair in Australia,
so I did use comedy
to make friends.
My parents put me in a different
school every year, so I did --
I was always kind of a jokester
or prankster I guess.
But professionally I didn't
really know that comedy
was really an option,
even though my dad is like
the funniest person
you would ever meet.
But, yes, Sacha was the one
that said, "You're so funny.
You say the funniest jokes.
You should do a comedy."
And then I told my agent,
and actually "Wedding Crashers"
was the first one
that I auditioned for,
and the rest is history.
Yeah, no, I'm lucky. I get to --
Like, "Wolf Like Me"
is very dramatic,
but I still get to do comedies
which is, you know,
tapping into your inner idiot.
The most fun you can ever have.
-I agree.
I have a lot of questions about
some other stuff
including your work
as an author.
We will be back with more
Isla Fisher right after this.